Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Alors je vais enfoncer une porte.
Mauvais jeu de mots,
puisque je vais vous parler scatologie.
Comme ça, direct et à froid,
dans un lieu aussi prestigieux.
Et je m’excuse par avance
de le faire de cette manière.
Car en plus, j’ai plutôt été très bien
accueillie par l’équipe pédagogique
qui s’est montrée très bienveillante.
Et je ne voudrais pas
qu’elle regrette trop son choix.
J'espère qu'il n'est pas trop tard.
En effet, je vais vous parler de bullshit.
Donc je m’excuse encore une fois
d’utiliser ce mot de Cambronne
dans un lieu chargé
d’histoire et de culture.
Littéralement, le bullshit,
c’est de la merde de taureau.
On parle de quelque chose d'assez odorant,
d'assez visible, d'assez conséquent.
Ce n'est pas le petit yorkshire du coin.
Là , vraiment, on est sur quelque chose
d’assez costaud.
Alors, vous savez, nous, Français,
comment nous sommes,
on est…
On arrondit les angles,
voilà comment le dire très aimablement,
nous sommes diplomates.
D’ailleurs, notre langue brille
de manière séculaire,
avec des mots qui restent intraduits
encore aujourd’hui :
laisser-faire, pourparler, touché,
sont des mots qu’on entend
en langue française.
Alors forcément,
pour nous Français, le bullshit,
c’est des fadaises,
des fariboles,
des foutaises.
Simplement, le réel nous invite
à appeler un chat un chat.
Parfois, le réel s'impose à nous.
Que nous le voulions ou non d'ailleurs.
Alors qui ?
Qui vous raconte de la merde ?
Qui vous polluent les oreilles ?
Les politiciens, certainement.
C’est pour rester un peu
dans l’ambiance du moment, bien sûr.
Mais ne vous inquiétez pas,
on ne va pas parler politique ce soir.
Les communicants, souvent.
Les pubeuxs, les marketeux,
les entreprises parfois.
Et si on est honnêtes
et lucides envers nous-mêmes,
eh bien on se rend compte aussi
que nous sommes
nos propres producteurs de bullshit.
Les chefaillons en tête.
On a tous plus ou moins
raconté des histoires
pour se sortir de certaines situations.
En utilisant beaucoup la langue de bois.
« J’apprécie énormément le temps
que je passe avec toi, vraiment !
Mais ce week-end, non,
je ne peux pas sortir.
Je dois me recentrer
sur mes impératifs, vraiment…
je dois rester concentré. »
Et puis finalement, le samedi soir,
Netflix Popcorn jusqu'à 3 h du matin,
voire même le selfie
avec les amis, dans le bar d’à côté…
Alors est-ce qu’on peut appeler
ça un mensonge ?
Depuis 2016 et l’élection de Donald Trump,
on parle de faits alternatifs.
Les termes “faits alternatifs” sont
rentrés dans le dictionnaire d’Oxford.
Il est vrai que les journalistes
avaient été un petit peu surpris
de voir le jeune président,
fraîchement élu,
saluer le soleil
et la foule venue très nombreuse.
Remarquez,
cet événement permet
de clarifier les choses,
de mettre un petit peu d’ordre
dans les définitions.
Une autre séquence me vient en tête.
Ça donnait quelque chose
à peu près de cet ordre-là :
« Je n’ai pas, Jean-Jacques Bourdin,
je n’ai jamais eu de compte en Suisse. »
Vous vous souvenez tous
de cette séquence ?
Elle est mémorable.
C’était Jérôme Cahuzac, à l’époque
ministre des Finances,
en charge de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale.
Bon, là, au global, la vérité,
tu as une assez bonne idée
de ce que c’est,
tu la planques bien comme il faut,
elle te fait même un petit peu peur.
Tu la tiens en respect.
Alors que pour le bullshiteur, la vérité…
C’est celui qui dit qui est,
comme quand on était petit.
Comme lorsque Alice au Pays des Merveilles
rencontre Humpty Dumpty
et il lui dit, non sans un air de dédain,
« Un mot que j’utilise signifie
exclusivement ce que je souhaite
qu’il signifie, ni plus ni moins. »
Alors Alice, curieuse, s’interroge :
« Mais comment donner
un sens différent au mot, alors ?
Comment arrive-t-on à se mettre d’accord,
si c’est chacun qui décide
de la signification d’un mot ? »
Humpty Dumpty lui répond :
« Il suffit de savoir qui est le maître,
c’est tout ! »
Cette séquence, ce passage littéraire
nous informe
des structures sous-jacentes
à l’œuvre dans le langage.
C’est peut-être ce qui faisait dire
à Roland Barthes d’ailleurs,
fameux sémiologue français,
« la langue est fachiste. »
Et c'est peut être ça d'ailleurs,
le désenchantement du monde.
Utiliser les mots,
comme s’ils étaient interchangeables,
déconnectés de la réalité,
comme si ça n’avait pas d’incidence.
Comme si ce n'était pas grave.
Comme si on pouvait juste les utiliser
pour leur technicité .
Pour convaincre.
Comme des outils.
C’est assez incroyable, cette période
que nous avons vécue, collectivement,
cette pandémie,
où tour à tour, nous avons été
confinés,
déconfinés,
reconfinés,
confinés dehors !
On ne pensait pas cela possible.
C’est vrai que les oxymores ont tendance
à nous rendre un petit peu fous
et à beaucoup nous inquiéter.
Alors on a tous trouvé un ou une amie
vers qui se tourner,
qui nous a sans doute rassuré.
Qui nous a dit « t’inquiète pas. »
Entre le charbon propre,
notre écologie de production,
ton pouvoir d’achat ressenti,
(bien sûr, pas le vrai,
pas celui du porte monnaie,
celui dans votre tête)
le pouvoir d’achat ressenti, celui-ci,
tu vas voir, il va être bien meilleur.
On va tous repartir
sur notre croissance négative, comme avant
et ça va très bien se passer tout ça. »
Voilà, voilà.
tout va pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes, donc.
Et pourtant,
il y a une autre vision que je souhaite
partager avec vous ce soir.
Et c'est pour ça que je suis présente.
Un autre message
que je souhaite vous délivrer.
C’est vrai que c’est une approche
complètement folle,
complètement décalée,
si disruptive qu’on ne l’entend
nulle part.
Les linguistes eux-mêmes ont mis
cette théorie loin, loin, loin, loin.
Il faut creuser
pour aller la trouver, la chercher.
Moi-même, il m’a fallu plusieurs années
pour comprendre
cette émergence.
Écoutez-moi bien.
Le sens ne se construit pas.
Il se révèle.
Il nous révèle.
Peut-être même que le sens nous préexiste.
Prenons un exemple.
Un seul exemple,
une structure anthropologique commune.
Un mythe fondateur
que chaque être humain sur Terre
va être amené à vivre,
à expérimenter :
tomber amoureux.
Vous avez bien entendu, tomber amoureux.
C’est vrai qu’on se lève pas le matin
en se disant : « Tiens,
je m’ennuie un petit peu aujourd’hui,
je ne sais pas quoi faire…
Et si je tombais amoureux ?
Non, c’est vrai que ça ne se passe
pas vraiment comme ça.
Plutôt quelque chose
qui nous tombe dessus.
Et c’est intéressant parce que…
le chercheur Luc Biget nous le rappelle,
il s’agit avant tout d’une chute,
une chute de l’ego.
Cette figure, cette image,
c’est quelque chose qu’on retrouve
dans de nombreuses langues,
pas qu’en langue française.
Tomber amoureux.
Quoi de plus émouvant
que le genou à terre du futur époux ?
Quoi de plus humble
que le genou à terre du chevalier
qui s’engage pour des valeurs
et une cause qui lui semblent justes ?
Quoi de plus simple que la posture
du croyant devant l’autel ?
Voire même de ceux qui portent un tombeau.
Ce n'était pas fait exprès.
Dans tous les cas,
il s’agit bien d’une “je nous flexion”.
Vous avez bien entendu.
“Je nous flexion”.
Cette chute de l’ego, c’est bien celle-ci,
c’est la chute du je au service du nous.
C’est le je qui se met de côté
pour que le nous puisse s’épanouir.
Alors c’est peut-être cela,
le réenchantement du monde.
Écouter les mots pour ce qu’ils ont
à nous chuchoter à l’oreille.
Ouvrir les yeux pour observer les symboles
tels qu’ils sont présents
et ce qu’ils nous racontent.
Renouer avec l’histoire de certains gestes
que nous effectuons de manière
mécanique ou conventionnelle,
sans savoir forcément d’où ils viennent.
Et peut-être aussi
que le réenchantement du monde,
c’est vivre sa vie
et la vivre poétiquement,
parce que le reste n’est que survivre.
Ça, c’est le philosophe français
Edgar Morin qui nous le rappelle.
Enfin, pour conclure,
j’ajouterai que le réenchantement
du monde,
c’est sans doute passer
de la méthode, justement,
à la “mythode”.
On entend le terme mythologie dedans.
C’est aussi passer du sens,
souvent analytique,
à la quintessence,
à la profondeur des choses.
De ceux qui raisonnent
à ceux qui résonnent en eux.
Accent aigü.
C’est aussi passer de la profusion
de la consommation des images
au pouvoir et à la puissance
des imaginaires.
Enfin, c'est passé du sacre au sacré
et c'est toute la différence.
Alors si vous aussi vous voulez être
des réenchanteurs du monde,
vous savez ce qu’il vous reste à faire.
Ouvrir les yeux, toujours
avec émerveillement,
et bien sûr, prêter l’oreille.
Je vous remercie.
Bonne soirée, surtout.